ايه افكار الرئيس الروسي الرئيس الروسي
افكاره واضحه جدا هو الراجل عبر عنها
بكلام يعني
علنا اكثر من مره هو يعتقد ان الاتحاد
السوفيتي سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي كان اكبر
كارثه سياسيه في القرن العشرين
تصحيحها مش معناه احياء الاتحاد السوفيتي
ولكن تصحيحها من وجهه نظره هو ان تصبح
روسيا بلد قوي وقوه عظمى قوه عظمى لانه من
وجهه نظره روسيا ليس لديها الخيار في الا
تصبح دوله قويه وبالتالي دوله عظمى ليه ما
عندهاش الخيار من وجهه نظر من وجهه نظر
كثير من المفكرين الروس الروس ما عندهمش
رفاهيه الخيار البريطاني يعني كان الدوله
عظمى ثم اصبحت دوله عاديه لكن دون ان يمس
ذلك بانها القومي لان بريطانيا سلمت
الرايه لحليف وائل الولايات المتحده
وتحتمي بعشرات من الحلفاء الغربيين اما
الروس فيعتقدون وضعوا سلاحهم فسوف يتم
تفكيكهم الغرب انتقل من سياسه الاحتواء ان
انا احاصر الاتحاد السوفيتي في مناطق
نفوذه دون ان يتمدد اكثر واكثر الى سياسه
التفكيك والتقويد انه يفكك الاتحاد
السوفيتي ثم يفكك روسيا الاتحاديه بحيث
تصبح لو امكن مثقفه فقط لا غير الكلام ده
مين اللي قاله الكلام اللي قاله ده الرئيس
الروسي رئيس الروسي دايما مشغول بصورتين
بيكررهم كثيرا فكره القلعه المحاصره روسيا
محاصره بالاعداء وفكره الدب الروسي
الذي يجب ان يظل دائما منتبها والا سوف
يقوم سجانه بتقييده وكسر اسنانه وتقليم
اظافره هو قال كده نصا بعد ان احتل شبه
جزيره القمه في 2014 لما بيسالوه انت ليه
عملت كده قال لهم انا عملت كده لانه اذا
الدب توقف عن حمايه غابته
وتوقف عن مطارده الخنازير وجلس مسالما
لياكل التوت والعسل هل سيتركونه وحده مين
هم بيتكلم على الغرب طبعا دائما يحاولون
تقييده بالسلاسل وبمجرد ان يقيدوه سوف
ينزعون اسنانه
ومخالبه ثم يقومون بتحنيطه اعملوا لعبه